que les voitures dermique techniques
doivent disparaît c'est une évidence ce
une technologie qui bien des égards mais
qui produit des émissions co2 en grande
quantité donc elle est vouée à
disparaître
la position de la france eire et bien
illustrative de l'ambiguïté totale du
président macky qui voudraient sèche
passer pour le grand écolo alors que dès
que les mesures nécessité par la
transition écologique
or les intérêts bien compris les
détenteurs de capitaux bas c'est là que
le mcs ronsard s est en effet il a
plaidé pour le maintien du moteur
thermique et des ventes de voitures à
moteur thermique jusqu'en 2040
nous pensons sadr et 2030 la commission
a tranché en 2035
on peut aussi mixer un objectif
ambitieux mais très franchement quand
j'entends les protestations du secteur
automobile je suis scandalisée
scandalisée je suis désolé de 10,2
secteur automobile
c'est aussi bien que le quiconque depuis
des années que les émissions de co2 il
va dévoiler les faits mais c'est
simplement il a voulu se jouer des
législateurs et des législations
il a triché avec c'est avec l'ennemi
d'éviter les nombres démission et lui
l'a fait en sorte qu'elle ne soit pas eu
mesurer le mal est réel et lui il a
triché et donc aujourd'hui il joue les
vertus effarouchées en disant mais c'est
beaucoup trop on va voir travailler les
gâches aujourd'hui si vous les méritez
vos profits et bien il va falloir
investir et en effet les investissements
d'aujourd'hui sont les profits de demain
mais se font au détriment des profits
immédiats et s'ils peuvent pas accepter
sahélien il y à certains de leurs
concurrents qui seront trop contents
d'eux
de prendre leur place
[Musique]